welcome back another huge controversy
over the national anthem
dallas mavericks owner mark cuban said
he was putting a halt to playing the
song before home games
but the nba is out with a statement it
reads
with nba teams now in the process of
welcoming fans back into their arenas
all teams will play the national anthem
in keeping
with long-standing league policy end
quote
and now cuban reportedly says he will
comply with the league's policy
and play the national anthem tonight
judge i just want to start with you the
nba season started in late december why
do you think it took so long for this to
become an issue he hasn't been playing
the anthem
since then well i think it seems that
it's because of the home games and
and now you know the nba has pretty much
issued
the officials at the nba have pretty
much issued that the that they will play
the national anthem
and mark cuban has kind of given himself
some leeway by saying well you know they
were really home games and there's no
one in the stands and now the people are
coming into the stands
then what we'll do is we'll play the
national anthem but
i think that the the telltale here is
that cuban said that he would kneel
too with his players if he had had the
chance i think that tells the whole
story
so he can dance around well it was a
home game there was no one in the
in these stands uh and now that the nba
has come out with the mandate he's going
to have to play it but his heart is with
well i kneel with them too and then when
you have a gensake saying
you know it recognizes the united states
failings i mean you get so disgusted you
really want people to come to games
you know or do you want people to not
watch them
so jesse do you take this as a protest
by the owner in line with colin
kaepernick
well he went full kaepernick and juan
you never go
full kaepernick what i think happened
here he was probably just trying to be
the wokest
nba owner to to recruit better because a
lot of young nba talents pretty
political he thought it would help him
sign him but i don't know i don't think
the season ticket holders
are going to be down with this the nba
is not even down with this
i mean kneeling is one thing canceling
the anthem
i mean we finally found out where the
line is with social justice
and mark flew right past it and got teed
up big time
i couldn't believe the white house tried
to both sides the issue
of cancelling the national anthem they
went
squishy on cancelling the national
anthem lawn
i mean in in basketball you'd call that
a brick
so greg i wanted to actually allow you
to hear from mark cuban here's something
he tweeted last year he said
if you want to complain complain to your
boss why don't
that doesn't your boss play the national
anthem every day
before you start work what do you think
of that defense
it's actually not a bad defense because
he is the boss and he's the owner
and he can do what he wants uh we've
seen this before
uh when we were kids if you and your
sister were fighting over what to watch
watch on tv after a while a parent would
come in and turn the tv off
it's called why we can't have nice
things right we can't have nice things
because we're now the media in general
are pledging allegiance to identity
politics
instead of the flag it is his team i
don't think it's
any call on his patriotism he was trying
to solve
a problem that reflects a sad sign of
the times
where identity politics where wherever
it goes
it it it it destroys
it it operates under the protective
guise of protest
but once it gets inside the organism
whether it's sports or entertainment or
tv shows
it unravels it it splits instead of
unites
all he's trying to do is trying to keep
it from splitting even more
unfortunately it may not help
so dana is this over now that the nba
has put its foot down and said
everybody's going to play the anthem
before every game
well it's also over because mark cuban
said okay i'm good i'll play the anthem
like so
instead of having any outrage i'm gonna
tell you do you know the history of why
we play national anthems
at sporting events i will tell you the
answer world war one
a game between the red sox and the
chicago cubs in 1918
that is a year that is familiar to
yankee fans is the last time the sox won
a world series before 2012. if you
remember that i mean i'm a his i'm a
sports
and a history buff so i knew all of this
anyway
that's why we do it it's good it's
unifying
it's america let's just move on no
outrage
all right ahead